التي تظهر الخلفيه الان هي سفينه جلاله
الملك الجبيل وهي احدى سفن اسطول البحريه
السعوديه المشاركه في عمليات الاجراء التي
تقوم بها الحكومه السعوديه من ميناء
بورسودان الى ميناء قاعده الملك فيصل
العسكريه هنا في مدينه جده السعوديه هذه
هي الرحله الثالثه التي تقوم بها هذه
السفينه من المختلط انها ستقل في طريق
عودتها الى هنا حيث القاعده الملك فيصل
رعايه من دول مختلفه الحكومه السعوديه
ومنذ اندلعت هذه الازمه وهي تقوم برحلات
انقاذ عبر سفنها الحربيه نتحدث عن استقبال
اكثر من عشرين سفينه اجلاء تحمل رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه لذلك يصل الاجمالي عدد
الذين تم اجلائهم منذ بدء العمليات نحو
5,500 شخص تقريبا من بينهم 225 مواطنا
سعوديا والبقيه ينتمون لاكثر من جنسيه
مختلفه السعوديه اكدت ان قوافل الانقاذ
وبرامج سوف تستمر من ميناء بورسودان الى
السعوديه هنا حتى يتم ايقاف النزاع المسلح
داخل الاراضي السودانيه هنا حينما تصل
السفن الى مدينه جده يتم استقباله من قبل
مسؤولية سعوديين وايضا من قبل الممثليات
السفارات بلدانهم ويتم توفير كافه الخدمات
لهم نتحدث عن اقامه استثنائيه لمده شهر
لكي يتم منها اجراءاتهم من قبل ممثليات
وقنصليات بلادهم المتواجده هنا في الميناء
في استقبالهم في كل رحله تصل الى السعوديه
بدل ربيعان قناه الجزيره من ميناء قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده